[Music]
hello everyone I'm Mary I'm joined by
the delightful Brad Mir from double fine
thanks for having me oh we are so glad
to have you and we are about to play I
wonder a lot of people probably thinking
I loved that movie gataka but I wish
there was a game that represented
Society in the not to distant future
where we decided that you weren't good
enough because of your genetic gene pool
oh man we yeah that's definitely
something we tried to fight against the
fact that like it's kind of feels like a
eugenic simulator when you're playing
there's no denying that that is it's
rough what this is um but it's still
amazing it's got kind of a little bit of
eugenics simulation and then it's got
this XCOM piece to it it's awesome we're
going to be playing it for the next hour
we're going to start a brand new game
I'm going to jump right into it and
we're just going to start figuring this
out I think what's going to end up
happening here uh as I play uh Brad is
going to slowly but surely judge my
decision
making we can totally we can totally
talk about and he's going to silently
realize that I've made a horrible
horrible decision what are we going to
name it whatever you like we we got to
get some skin in the game I know you
also have been practicing very much for
this game by also having oh my God by
extending your own genetic absolutely
absolutely yeah I just my wife and I
just had our first child congratulations
we had a son his name is Gibson Gibson
Gib just like the guitar yeah like spell
like the guitar um also yeah spelled
like the guitar more like the um uh the
supercomputer in the movie hackers
oh that is really that's not really what
it's a it's a family name it's a family
name I just like that it happened to be
the the supercomputer it's hard to
please everyone when you choose a name
for a kid though it's really hard we
also we kept it a secret all the way up
until we uh until we launched our baby
oh really just cuz if you tell people
ahead of time they might give you an
opinion that you might not like uh yeah
so it I we found it was best to wait and
it worked it worked out really well cuz
now no I mean when you hand someone a
baby and you're like here's his name
nobody's going to talk about the
baby right when they're like holding a
beautiful little child they will they
just won't do it to your face that's the
kind of thing where you decide secretly
like can you believe like that kid is
going to totally get it in school and
you say you know what shut up
okay so this part of the game you can
actually pick like uh the starting
houses that you want and all of those
were like made by our Kickstarter
backers and stuff I I love that there's
an option for here where a lot of the
names of the people that you fight with
are Kickstart Kickstarter backers chose
them and some of them are absolutely
just are ridiculous Yeah we actually had
to create a second category for ones
that I thought were like we just called
it not thematically appropriate just I
couldn't come up with something like way
that's the really ni you know possibly
[Laughter]
racist not appropriate there a lot there
were a lot of things that were just not
appropriate that we just flat out
rejected we just flat out rejected a
bunch of them but theor from the house
of
butts see that's fine that's not super
offensive but yeah there's you know
blackace McGill Cy whatever like there
were some there were some really awful
things nobody I just made that one up I
just made that one up but there were
plenty of things that people submitted
that were also lots of copyright in that
we had to be like yeah we uh we can't
put Harry Potter into the game like
sorry that's I think that's going to
come after to me like what I consider
the hardest part about Kickstarter is
that you want people to feel like they
have skin in the game right that they
are involved in the process but at the
same time I want a bunch of scrub blets
deciding what I'm going to name my
characters in case they do something
stupid this my game and I want to make
sure it's good so it's a very hard
balance it was it was rough because that
that was basically our Safeguard against
it we just decided what we felt was kind
of like thematically that's the the
category the thematically appropriate
one it's such a beautiful uh way to just
absolutely filter out everything you
deem not appropriate in any way because
it's a very broad right you can say that
for anything you can say anybody's not
right yeah atically not appropriate oh
so so yeah so like let talk about this
game yeah yeah this video game hey like
to set it up so uh you as a player you
take the role of this Immortal ruler
that's kind of taking uh safeguarding uh
this nation and it's under attack by
this thing called the Cadence which um
you'll see the map later on it's this
kind of like weird choking miasma that's
that's kind of encroaching on on the
kingdom um so so the game kind of takes
place in two Hales so this is the the
Tactical portion of the game where
you're going to um be controlling five
heroes in from this like three4
perspective right and uh and sort of
like eliminating all the enemies on the
map like very human scale like this is
really familiar for people that have
played uh like any kind of like tactical
strategy games any kind of turn-based
yeah XC uh Fire Emblem uh Final Fantasy
Tactics those are like yeah those are
like all of the um all the games that
were really inspirational to me and and
and the team like a lot of we took a lot
of cues from them and I think you know
you absolutely can feel that when you
play this I love it but it's almost it
goes a little further I think with um
well we're going to see later how you're
actually ending up passing time and and
deciding Bloodlines and things like that
but for right now um you know what we're
doing right now is we're looking at our
our our current clan we got uh Kelly
master um that's m l Master to you and
she she she's got some problems she's
clumsy and slow and she gets nervous
which means she's not as accurate this
is one one of the worst characters I've
seen in the game of Master sorry she's
still a hero though her unfortunate
still good but yeah so but she's young
so she's super fertile you know to like
pass on all those clumsy slow jeans that
I totally want right great um you can
move it around to see your stats she's
she's young she's 18 so she is able to
vote good for her um but she you know
hopefully she can survive long enough to
get that uh you'll see uh when when this
is all um randomly generated this all
the um so not not just the people but
like the lands that you're playing on
which makes it really feel unique each
and every time and um I found sometimes
when I start this game I got uh I like
four Alchemists and it's a completely
different playthrough and a lot of it um
can be really annoying when that happens
because you want a broad range but it
forces you you know roll the dice just
like in life hey yeah there is a lot of
Randomness in the game we do have to to
address that one specifically so there
are three core classes in the game um
there's uh so that was The Alchemist
kind of like our medium uh medium range
like AOE damage class uh and then you
have a cjack so this is a cjack which is
like our close range um kind of like you
know just like heavily armed melee
combat smash them up and then uh the
next character that you have is a hunter
mhm which is just like our single Target
long range class um fights with like a
giant crossbow and we do have an option
in the game when you start and I believe
it's on by default uh to make sure that
you get a a nice mix of all the classes
right um that was something we went uh
we went through Early Access with this
game oh I've had it and it's it can it
can it's rough right like before we had
that like we when we shipped in Early
Access we did not have that option and
it was something that came from the
community that they were just like you
know I I thought it was kind of
interesting to start with like you know
maybe you don't even have any Alchemists
like in your in your playr right and you
want you want to figure out what they're
like right you want to learn their moves
so that you understand what the heck
they're doing because by the time this
this game progresses really fast I'm
going to hurry up and go through all
these tutorial pieces but it it goes
really fast and you might be you might
surprise yourself when you find out that
uh you know the next three battles get
freaking hard and if you don't start
learning your stuff now this is like the
polite battle and people die in the nice
battle all the time they really get your
together oh my God that guy's name
was drunk oh no no no that was uh was
that oh he is drunk yeah hit Z on that
guy just just jump into that guy so see
his personality he's a rer and if you
scroll down so so that's uh so it's kind
of split into uh genetic traits which
are the three on the top and then the
personality traits can't have drunk
cjacks listen actually when you're drunk
your strength increases so it's actually
really good for uh for a melee combatant
like a like a camera Jack W that's real
I'm also I get increased strength when I
drink
too I think most people do yeah we try
it's actually it's pretty accurate
simulation I really appreciate that I
really appreciate that ability you'll
notice all these people have a little HP
above them for each hit they take um you
know they can that'll go down it can go
down uh later some of the enemies they
take like 10 points away from you so you
know this game is punishing for any
mistake you make and you need to be
really aware of that because you can
just straight up totally eat it if
you're not paying attention and I I've
lost so many people and this is just
that XCOM way right where you where you
feel like you got it and you know you do
roll the dice and
unfortunately uh you know you get killed
um once I complete my turn it makes me
take a break I'm trying to figure out
where the map is taking me here it looks
like I'm going down this secret Corridor
um yeah if you keep rolling in this
direction you should be able to find the
enemies I always try to play it safe by
staying in the orange but I'm going to
take a few risks yeah right so all the
characters have two action points um
very similar to the new XCOM system I
just I really like that game yeah um I
think you're in good company here it's
it's there's a lot ofs to make yeah we
took a lot of cues from guy so slow oh
you know what I think he is slow and he
has asthma let's check it out oh no yeah
he's asthma oh no no you know what it is
he has asthma and then he's a rer as
well except this time he entered the
battle uh hung over scroll down a little
bit he's hung over his speed and his
evasion his HP are all low oh my C Jacks
are drunk every one of them what a waste
um and that you know we tal we talked
about Eugenics on the top and that's
like I you know I didn't want the game
to be just like a total eugenic
simulation so we kind of split it
between um their genetic traits and then
their personality traits so you can have
people that have like bad genetics but
good personalities just like real life
and you actually don't mind hanging out
with those people and they can be really
good in a fight look at how slow this
idiot is Oh's so slow yeah he just had
another asthma ATT he had an asthma
attack everyone's thank God there's been
no bad guys everybody here would be dead
I think head up to the right into there
I think no everyone's drunk I have a
really low chance of survival here okay
here we go okay so this is the Cadence
this is the enemy that we're trying to
get rid of here yeah so every every
roughly 10 years the Cadence will will
generate we call them pawns they're just
the these like humanoid enemies that you
fight um on the like tactical
battlefields um and they they do that to
sort of like increase the corruption in
uh in the lands and then eventually like
destroy uh parts of the map we'll see
that when we get back to the uh to the
strategy
view but yeah for now that that little
guy that little enemy is called a seed
it's sort of like the standard melee
enemy um it's really annoying he seems
like he can be taken out pretty easily
but he's a real real yeah they have
slightly higher evasion than the than
the than the base enemies um and then
when they when they deal damage they
they'll leech a little bit of life too
so they they do tend to be like super
annoying to fight um you get multiple
move options I think this is pretty neat
um and it also tells you the percentage
chance likely of a hit um there's also
like a little eyeball it's telling you
whether or not you can see them there's
all sorts of visual details here that
are helping you understand how the
likelihood of you actually killing these
these people and they're all really
important that you uh you
know understand what the heck you're
doing you have this it's fine confir
Final Answer God you piece of
silently judging me it's only
because I'm here it's only because I'm
here W statistically if my drunk people
die I'm going to be really upset so uh
so The Alchemist can can either use uh
they're they're kind of like we just
call thrower their big claw they can use
that um as a melee weapon or you can
throw you have a limited number of
flasks but they do hit in a 3X3 area
that's right and you can hurt your own
people so you have to be really careful
with the way you choose use them uh
because you can you can kill your own
dudes that happens uh especially you
know if they're hung over and not paying
attention during the fight or maybe
they're so slow that they're missing the
entire fight this guy's going to miss
the whole battle he's having an asthma
attack you're not even there what are
you so afraid of like nothing could
possibly happen to you and we found that
you know like we wanted we wanted these
like like the traits the genetics and
the personalities to have like a lot of
impact on the fight and like you can
totally see that guy in the back like
he's yeah he's just terrible he's
terrible also that you had I noticed one
of your um one of your Alchemists is
nervous has decreased accuracy so that
could be super super dangerous when
you're throwing those laughs around
everyone wants me dead here and it's
just oh so this is a good so if you see
the like where you're potentially moving
to yeah oh you can actually hit him from
where you're standing but just I can I
have 72% chance not bad so I think I
might try to take the shot considering
just uh not not too long
ago uh
I him from like three blocks away you
you got this one
though you piece of hate that guy
oh my God that is the worst um you can
also you can also right click as a
shortcut
um no see that that's fine he's Wy and
Wy and puny yeah well I'm going that's
stupid I don't like him gu has been no
good to me useless on the battlef in I
really really prefer um I really like
the Archer guys because you don't run
out of those whereas these Alchemists
you can run out and it's very very
frustrating I don't know if I'm going to
be able to get to him from here I can
try I think it's all right I'm going to
have to hold out yeah you stay put is
there a way to just skip the oh I can
end the turn just end his turn yep I'll
just end all my turns because I don't I
want him to come to me and that's a good
strategy right like sometimes you you
want to wait until the the right time
yeah and I think you were out of sight
range of that guy so it was now you
idiot fine I'm like throw this flask out
oh 44% I like those odds yeah yeah all
right go for it I like to live
dangerously yeah so the the good thing
with the Alchemist is that even if you
were to miss that shot it's going to
land somewhere and with like a 3X3 area
like you might actually end up still
killing it and it's like what difference
does it make at that stage like come
come oh this guy's hammered he's so
drunk he's 15
he's not even the legal age wait is is
he only 15 I didn't see that it said 15
oh my God I believe it let me see we
never discussed what the age 15 and
drunk as drunk arek bad everything
else though that's pretty good Bountiful
hearty that's that character is pretty
good outside of being drunk Prett so I
made a mistake I brought him out here he
saw the guy but now he's out of moves so
he's he's in danger he'll be fine you
know people are going to get hurt in
this game that's just like just like
real life just like life if you want to
make an omelet you got to kill a few of
your best players uh the the hunter
right here would be a good time to use
that second ability two they can sneak
around um so you can use a stealth
ability to go up uh kind of like like we
limit it to really tall kind of objects
in the environment so if you go up in
any of those diamonds you can you can
move to and then your character will
turn turn invisible to the enemies you
can sneak around and Scout um it's super
super useful that's really useful for
later a lot of these things you're
telling me right now would have been
really good to know when I was playing
this in Early Access you guys just
launched this week but you've been in
Early Access for some time yeah since
about uh I think it was October last
year that we that we launched into he's
so slow yeah did you learn anything from
Early Access did Early Access help you
to change anything about the game yeah I
mean there were a lot of there were a
lot of suggestions that made their way
directly into the game one of the
biggest ones was that people were people
were bummed out that there were only
three classes in the game and we had
this feature um die we had this feature
that was sort of like on was like on the
back burner it didn't quite make it for
like our Early Access release and uh
it's the concept of hybrid classes so
when you marry two characters together
on a strategy layer um depending on what
class uh like if they're different
classes the kids that are produced will
actually be um kind of like a mixture of
both of their skills hopefully we'll see
that when we get to the get to the
strategy side oh that's a new one
she's the beast I don't like I don't
like those yeah so so all the enemies
are based on um kind of like weird uh it
it sounds like really nerdy when I say
it but they're like they're meant to be
like the the physical manifestations of
time
passing so so like this character is
supposed to it's like a memory loss uh
it's kind of like our like our
Alzheimer's alist is oh no it's terrible
is in trouble all right so what I'm
going to do is I'm GNA um try to
yeah that seems good this guy I might
even get closer because I'm not taking
any risks yeah you might also want to
pull that guy out completely what ends
up happening with uh would you say The
Alchemist the uh flasks or the attack
ends up being more brutal to them oh I
mean it's it's kind of I think the they
do roughly the same damage uh kind of in
the ballpark but you know the you really
want to be using the flash like in that
case it's much better to just use the
melee attack if you're close enough to
use it
some of them though because some of the
bad guys
uh will actually hurt you after you kill
them like they can explode there's a lot
of and there's environmental damage too
I remember just the other day I was
playing and uh oh man he's too can't get
him um but maybe my amazing Archer yeah
this guy is this guy terrible huh is the
one see this is where you shine 80%
probably not going to kill it but look
at that hey he actually some content
finally did something where's my other
idiot there he is this is the super slow
guy and he's probably going to have
another asthma attack right here watch
this is really stressing me out oh man
all right and I'm going to end my turn
there's not much I can do here which
means I'm going to get a little bit more
attacked but my guy
who's stupid see see like the that's
validating because I shouldn't always
feel like you know statistically I'm
just going to die here like they they
get hurt too and they they make mistakes
and they don't always succeed and that's
very you know XCOM like you know we try
to make it fair you know we try to make
it fair because it's it's annoying if
the if you feel like the AI always has
the advantage over like what you're
doing you know when you're both feel
like you're operating inside the same
system I think it's I think it's a lot
more satisfying Oh my he missed another
one God oh no and now you know what he's
actually blocking your other characters
from like running in from melee from
melee I have an I have you could move
that Alchemist up and throw a bomb over
over his head yeah that would totally
work that's a good idea all
right this one has a higher chance yeah
but I would throw it it goes a little
earlier then it get back this could be
really bad all right here we go no
regret okay no regret okay he missed but
it it went the other way it went the
other way that's fine I am surrounded by
morons you could also you know the other
Alchemist could move up and try again
this guy yeah no he's in danger zone I
want to keep everyone alive I agree with
my goal is for people I respect it no
you're done you're done you stay in that
corner you think about it that's the
slow guy anyway you don't care about him
care about
him all right it's your time to shine
Archer I expect something from you here
I'm going to make this so easy on you
I'm going to make this so easy on
you is oh right and now that can um he
explodes when he dies oh that's it so
that's it nice what a massive chalice
Victory massive Victory you got it good
for me is did you guys ever get like
kind of Victory if I lose like four of
them we still we still consider it a
massive Victory me too um yeah let's
look at it and then now so for the
different people who um get kills they
end up leveling up so I've gotten little
points for them and I can unlock skills
which is really enjoyable it makes you
really appreciate um putting value into
the same Heroes right because you're
actually they're growing they're getting
they're getting better so um I don't
really have any choice right now yeah we
just this is sort of like our you know
you have been chosen training all right
that's it training you and I think you
had one other guy yeah cjack Ryan dice
old Ryan that's such a future is this
the guy this can't be the guy that was
no no no the drunk the the the the
asmatic slow guy did not he didn't do
anything didn't do anything I will
remove his extra points myself he did
nothing you are
worthless all right so I think that's it
and now I get to O Hamachi Dice look at
all these dices yeah that's kind of cool
that like that was one thing that we did
kind of early on in development when we
were playing the game is that uh so you
start with 15 Heroes you get five in
your initial party and then there are 10
that are back in the capital which is
that building in the center of the map
that's kind of like your home base
that's right where it all and they were
all different they were all different uh
characters they were all from different
houses but as we played it we were like
like like giving you some immediate
familial connections like those are
probably two brothers was it Hamachi
people submitted some some strange names
that we were like yeah I guess those
arei and Ryan yeah the parents you know
very creative but they're also very
conservative yeah right they like yeah
it's like they got divorced shortly
after you know opposites attracted and
so one was very was kind of a weird
hippie and other very straight lacei is
more
wild straight you have to name them
right away so you don't know maybe
hasashi is like the super buttoned up
one and Ryan is like crazy that's right
you can't judge someone based on their
name and a lot of those things are just
like random too you'd like to think that
they're all very uh pre-decided and
thought out and stuff my um stepmom's
name is Terry her mom wanted to name her
Teresa but she was so exhausted after
child birth all she could out get out
was Terry and that's her name yeah so
she could just be like Terry and that's
it so that's the way she was and that's
so this is so so this is the map of the
nation this is like what you're
defending
and kind of like thee uh weird goop on
the outside that is the Cadence that's
kind of corrupting the nation from the
outside in so the the diamonds in each
region those represent um the amount of
corruption and we'll see that a little
bit later like when the Cadence attacks
again we not because uh ain't nothing
getting corrupted nothing I'm sure
nothing bad will happen a good play
through I've got you by my side the
first thing we need to do is uh select a
keep to emplo a regent and partner to
start a bloodline so we're going to
start making babies yeah this is the
best part so where do we
recommend go to the keep yeah that was
just the one that you were defending we
start building buildings later on as
well oh look at all the
ladies so this is where you're actually
like uh you know choosing a region this
is the best part of the game this really
is because this isn't about you know
this isn't about politics this is about
keeping Humanity alive and whatever you
guys say or whatever it's not a problem
I need to keep everyone alive I'm going
to choose the best people to make babies
and if that happens to be like a
six-year-old lady and a 15-year-old dude
that's tough we don't so yeah we don't
have any restrictions on that that's up
to you if you want to go down you know
if you want to drive it to creepy bille
that's like totally up to you well it's
my bloodline and who Hamachi dice how
you doing there Hamachi there he is he's
brainy but he is asthmatic so these are
things that you need to cut out
immediately there are things that you
got to get rid of you got to get rid of
you got to get rid of asthma you got to
get rid of heart disease you got to get
rid of there's a lot of bad things in
the game but it's it's it's really
interesting though like I think that
people's brains like tend to gravitate
towards the bad things like there are a
lot of there a lot of other good things
like this guy's brainy and young at
heart and Optimist like she's great you
know she's great I really like her I'm
going to uh Angel Le mullinar look she
gets a point off for having a weird name
but's but
I like her uh you know sometimes you
want a lot of babies so if you see the
green uh oh that means they're super
fertile the green sex symbols that means
they like making babies yeah so that's
the Bountiful trait see the thing about
Ryan dice is is like um you can also
pass
on learned traits as well like if he's
drunk it's really possible he's going to
teach his children to be drunk um
because he's always passing the bottle
around such an honest game it's like so
brutally and aggressively honest it's
pretty good though like Bountiful Hardy
quick study those are like some of the
best some of the best traits but then
for sure you have to worry about that
rer uh personality getting passed on to
all of the children I know but you can't
win them all and I also like uh I like
him I like I like this so I think I'm
going to point uh Ryan dice definitely a
lot to think about though because you've
got the the personality traits the
genetic traits you also how high level
they are they will train they'll pass on
some of their experience to the children
it's hard though um I don't know if
we've mentioned this yet once once you
point them
they retire from Battle because making
babies is a fulltime job yeah it's a
fulltime job
um I'm pretty confident that you can
have a baby in one hand and and a c the
C is a two handed weapon we got all
two-handed weapons here I hold it I
guess you could get some sort of like an
urg you know like a like one of those
front packs you could have the baby on
and then yeah yeah yeah yeah the weird
things get it in a sling you do that
with your kid where you put them in oh
yeah all over the place it's the best
are you going to put them on a leash
when they get when they start walking
around are theity I think we're pro Le
we're going to be a pro leash household
especially in the city like geez leash
household the this is when you really
learn so you can also see like as you're
picking um uh we call it the partner so
it's the Regent and the partner and
those terms are specifically chosen to
be like uh non-gendered cuz you can
totally take a woman and have her be the
head of the household have her be the
Regent um but but yeah right now you've
chosen this this Ryan guy to sit there
and so this is the partner that you're
marrying into the family she's asmatic
and so if they were to have um different
classes like like this so this is a
cjack and you're marrying her him maybe
to like uh what is that to a hunter
you'd end up with what's called a shadow
Jack so that's okay so that's new and
that's really oh yeah you have not seen
this cool kind birth this new type of so
this is good this is a good one yes I
like this um and also level two as well
that's good cuz the kids will be a
little bit higher level when they come
out great you know also she's a cougar
and I like that that's right she's 31
he's 15 but she's young at heart yeah
which it's what's on the inside that
counts right isn't that what we say
absolutely whatever you're getting
married you have no
choice and that's definitely like like
they they do what you say for the most
part they they're gonna they're going to
do what you say but you know the whole
the whole Nation's on the line well you
know I'm doing the best I can I want you
guys to make babies so I got uh oh
there's no heroes in training right uh
that's it that's it that's all we can do
that other tab there that will be a
record of like all of the traines that
have ever been trained at this keep it's
a lot to take in that will be good for
my knowledge of knowing where I went
wrong so that I can Revel in my past
mistakes this game could have also been
called Captain hindsight because my God
basically you just find a mistake and
then don't realize that you've ruined
your game and you actually cannot win 10
hours later and it is a miserable
feeling but then you go back and you do
it again don't you yeah well I feel like
there's so much um there's so much
Randomness and like procedurally
generated stuff in the game that you can
you know when you go through it your
first time you're probably going to make
a lot of mistakes but you're going to
learn a lot along the way like as you go
through so as long as you don't mind
starting over you're going to do so much
better your second time you know or your
third time or your fourth time yeah I
absolutely would say for anyone who's
never given this game a shot you you can
get a lot of play out of it and you're
going to have to right because not only
is everything procedurally generated so
you get this nice original game feel
every time you play but there's no way
in hell you're going to beat the game on
your first try um so you might as well
just get adjusted to playing it a few
times and this really does it gives you
that but it also grants you a lot of
satisfaction when you don't win even if
you're not like succeeding and you know
you're going to lose you still enjoy the
process along the way of you know making
making babies and doing the thing you
like to do um yeah so so the Chalice uh
is kind of seated there right like in
the capital at the center the nation
that's kind of where you are like like
like I like to think of the game sort of
being like this almost like first person
kind of kind of feel you're seated in
this Throne as the ruler and you're like
like you're sort of in the throne room
and the Chalice is advising you how
Regal um so with two voices yeah cuz
it's got like split personality disord
yeah no it's it's like well we don't go
into it really but it's kind of like two
people that have have been like like
bound to this weird giant object and
then they're they're like in there and
they're they're kind of talking to you
and they give you advice as you go
through the the game like that and then
this is where you'll actually conduct
your research so this is you have a
single research pipe in the game and
there's lots of like weapons and armor
and items and and stuff like that but
you can only really pick one right
there's all these things do one thing
all these this is this is so cruel look
at all these options that I have and I
can only pick one this is like the main
thing of just too many choices and
they're all good but I think it's very
important and most people say at the
very beginning you got to keep making
children because you can lose if you run
out of Heroes and people are going to
die so it's really important to build
build new keeps so I'm going to start
with that and then we're going to do
some weird stuff after that and we'll do
that's I totally I totally recommend
that yeah so the uh the outer regions
all so the outer regions get corrupted
first so they'll be the first that to
get attacked um so the inner regions are
safer bets but if you build in the outer
regions you actually get bonuses um for
building out there that's kind of we try
to incentivize you actually be building
out there you want to live dangerously
you know that I do okay let's do it here
we go okay so yeah once you've made all
your once you've made all your decisions
like on the strategy layer you just hit
the big play button up there we go and
then you'll see the the days kind of
start ticking and then the years will
start ticking oh my gosh and then
somebody already died like time through
the hour like what is it through like
sand through the hour these are the days
of our lives but then there's like all
this drama because she like took my
husband and I don't like that you did
you can see the Red Skull up there
though somebody died of old age and now
there's a baby but now you have a baby
so so I mean this is the circle of life
this is very Lion King oh look at him
you can actually grab Nemesis dice seems
like an impressive name well this is
okay so they had Ryan
Hamachi and now Nemesis the dice are
known for their really weird names and
they're
drinking also so the personality traits
we don't set those until after the kids
come of age at age 15 but they're gen
are locked right away so um so yeah so
Nemesis is nearsighted oh God dang it he
you can also grab the baby and spin it
around thumb sucker you're weak your
weak Nemesis he's only he's only
nearsighted he's fine he doesn't even
know it's a thumb he's got to get it
real close
to all right so we've made a baby
congratulations and now we keep playing
right we just keep going yeah that's
kind of the thing is that we wanted it
to be like very fire and forget where
you like set up make all your decisions
and then you just let time go sort of
like Zen out and wait for things to
happen oh oh my research is done so now
I can uh start making more babies yeah
so your first so you know you talked
earlier about like wanting to have a
diverse kind of range of Heroes so your
first uh your first house was a cjack
house so you probably want to look at
either a hunter or Alchemist house for
this one train various ones I picked a a
perk I picked Camille because she's very
fertile but I got to look at everything
else now she's asmatic asmatic and slow
that's terrible
worthless oh also so Kelly L master has
that Vanguard tag so the Vanguard is the
group of five Heroes that you have so
those are like the ones that you fought
your last battle with it's just a
reminder because if you were to retire
her you'll you know you'll come into the
next battle and you'll have holes you
have people that are missing because you
retired them can I fill them with
somebody else absolutely you can take
you can take any of these people and put
them into the next fight but it's just
like a nice having like a nice reminder
that it's like oh yeah I was fighting
with this character yeah and I liked her
yeah but actually I didn't because she
missed half of her shots so I want to
like she did didn't she I she's going to
die in a battle soon anyway all these
people are just sick
and nervous fainthearted Reckless sickly
clumsy oh that character is terrible the
L Master bloodline not a good one
actually this was the guy that was
missing all the time wasn't it this
Griffin heart disease and puny oh and
he's already 34 and he has heart disease
so like that's he's not going to last
too much longer God everyone is
asthmatic I am stuck with the worst
people that's another C you have a ton
of like experienced cjacks I don't want
cjack what about what about this uh that
character right there
masculine masculine Dorian she's
asthmatic but quick so those sort of
like for God's sake that's okay though
cuz those sort of like those sort of
like cancel each other out a little bit
what does that mean though how can you
be a quick asmatic you run really fast
you can run really fast you're a
sprinter that's you're a
sprinter but but Astic never going to
run a marathon but you know if you need
100 meter dash quick like lightning this
is the guy that you know he's your guy
but then he needs to have his inhaler
with him yep always always all right
whatever you're the best of all the crap
I have I'm a pointing you and then we
need to find so C was no all the ladies
suck every one of them they're all did
you get a bad lady you got a bad lady
roll I have all it
happens bad dice asthmatic clumsy slow
nervous puny clumsy asmatic she's just a
whole a whole basket of garbage jeans
dimwitted she's an
idiot that's that's bad Al as
well brainy and puny that's that's you
know what bad too bad doesn't just it
just means their HP might be a little L
lowered strength but like that's not so
bad uh for the Alchemist so yeah I think
that that's maybe being cocky makes up
for it she's the rud of of cab Jacks she
really wants I can be I can do it guys
put me in yeah all right go for you're
going to get your
wish make some babies and so they'll
make uh they'll make what's called a
brutalist so that's an alchemist that
has like a bunch of uh like additional
Mele attacks and
stuff now so now what do you want to do
uh well I think we should I don't know I
think we should make something else
different something we haven't done in a
while I like there's so many options uh
armor is always very very important to
help to and like later on if you don't
have it you're not going to make it but
you're you're very frustrating you you
only let me do one person's type of
armor at a time and this takes a long
time this is 12 years what my
researchers are even doing well to speed
it up you could also make a sarite guild
so in the buildings um there's three
different kinds of buildings so there's
the keep that you already built and then
there's uh what's known as The Crucible
which is where you can appoint someone
you can retire someone and appoint them
as a trainer to help train up all of the
um all of the kids in the nation make
them smarter and then there's another
one called the third one is called the
St right Guild and you can retire Heroes
have them become stage rights and then
they just sort of for the rest of their
lives they become researchers and they
speed up uh your research so if you take
and that also retires them so like once
you do that you're not fighting and you
can't make babies you're like this lone
nonsex book reader and you just do that
for the rest of your life and that's it
that's what you do it's like taking the
black it is yeah it's actually you know
what go to the wall we we discussed it
and it's cuz they're uh they lose their
last name and they lose their uh their
sigil like those flags and their colors
and so yeah we talked about it's kind of
taking the white in massive chalice is
going to be a sage right and just
helping out these are the this is what
we've decided I went with Hunter armor I
think it's important uh it seems good so
see you in 12 years yep good luck
hopefully we don't get attacked here's
hoping for 12 years until I get that
sweet armor
come on but you got plenty of babies
popping out so that's good look at all
these babies popping out okay so now
this is like roughly every 10 years uh
the Cadence will like have enough energy
to make these pawns and attack uh attack
the nation and usually they'll attack at
least they're attacking my at least two
territories they're attacking where I've
got my my keep here and if they win so
like if they fill up these I lose my
keep yeah you'll lose the entire uh that
entire region well I got to protect it
and the building and everything else
will go away so you can only defend one
of those two things but yeah oh my God I
L yeah so that's you you retired a
couple of two of them became uh baby
makers know um so now I got to make new
Heroes and I gotta be really this is
really interesting too is when I do this
I actually might uh want to a certain
degree like people who I I don't mind
dying because it's true yeah if you have
somebody that's like pseudo Expendable
you might want to have them be like the
fifth slot you know because it's it's
like why not oh you know what I kind of
need to know what I needed to fill in is
there a way to look at everyone okay so
I got an alchemist I got a
hunter now I got a good mix here so I
can choose basically
anyone um so I just want to pick someone
who's good um this guy's level
two that's pretty good that's not bad at
all all right we'll go with ra Ry Hollow
crigger what who made that name I don't
know man oh man that was one cool thing
is that we got like instantly we had
like I don't know maybe maybe a thousand
of these things Cherry
Marshall there's so many like average
names and then just out like totally
crazy fantasy out the woodwork clumsy as
met you're going in good
luck good luck to you all right
deploy good luck also told me what I was
against told me I was going against
seeds and that's actually what fighting
in the last one well right so it's it's
good because I'm comfortable I know
those guys later on there are these just
vile sacks of crap that basically shoot
stuff out of their butts into the air
and then it lands on you and it takes
like 10 to 15 damage like it's just to
the uh the cradles and it does it every
turn so you just can't do anything and
they can also spawn like these this kind
of Base enemy the seed uh yeah the
Cradle can can spit additional seeds
like out onto the battlefield and it can
get really out of control when you have
just a ton of these guys oh no was that
the same guy yeah you didn't replace him
man worthless worthless all of you
absolutely worthless oh I got two now
hey uh I think it's going to be too
far 32% but for him to get over here is
really really that's like a long pretty
I don't think he's going to make it so
I'm just going to end that turn and make
them come to me that's a fine Choice um
you know roll the dice here see that was
two moves you can even watch them pause
so you know where their moves are I
did negative one you
wimp so uh melee can't miss God oh my
God that guy is
terrible oh no his bow is touching
him
what I hate you that's only 52% how it's
melee how is is that
possible whatever yeah okay so that's
the glancing below so yeah melee attacks
we don't let them Miss but they can do
about like 10% damage which is most of
the time just like one or two points you
guys are all
worthless oh wait that was a
mistake so that's if you're right
clicking yeah sometimes like a little
careful a little careful don't worry I
got this oh no it's another glancing
blow are they all drunk again I don't
think anybody's drunk this time which is
nice it's a good change of pace
unbelievable all
right all right I'm try to get this guy
well he's only got 10 HP I worry about
him well he should have thought about
that tough
okay all right coat
Neo those battle an Asma attack those
were also those also those were also
sent in by uh by the community oh my God
I will never for get some of them a lot
of Latin people love Latin that's what I
learned when it's it's like oh here's a
here's you know an opportunity for you
to like come up with a house motto or
like a battlecry this one's for my
homies
like there you go okay that kind leveled
up as well um we let you actually pick
uh pick their abilities like like if you
click that guy again mhm
um yeah we let you level them up on the
battlefield that's nice and it's funny
this is actually um one of the designers
on the game uh John Helm he was like he
fought really hard for that feature
because sometimes like if you have an
80-year-old
man uh or woman on the battlefield like
that's probably going to be their last
fight right so it's kind of nice if they
level up while you're while you're in in
combat you can actually like pick a new
ability for them and get to use it
before they die seem it seems nice that
you would get to use your one skill
before you die and it's a really good
argument too for anyone on the
development team it it was like uh you
know cuz it's always always you know
designers against programmers is sort of
like the the typical battle that you
have because the designers want tons of
features and uh programmers have to
implement all of those and it can get
rough at times but yeah um I think it's
a it's a great argument to make sure
that man idiot this is not going well I
know he's got a lot of Life he's fine
yeah surrounded he going to be in range
no he's one pile off thanks that is
awful good job everyone
all right but I should be able to shoot
him or not you know because my archers
suck they're all as you got this yes
that was he finally got one do your
job do you deserve a nice rewarding
asthma attack enjoy it you could also
sneak this guy up okay all right yeah I
got to use my use my hot skills uh and
then I'll just put him behind this rock
that's a good place for him and then he
can do the sneak so oh no that's cck
charge oh he doesn't have it all right
so he's done I'll just hold out you will
I I remember that the initial yeah
that's totally fine that that first
match that you made was a cjack and a
hunter so they're going to have Shadow
Jacks which are cjacks that uh that have
a sneaky that's really help awesome the
map is really uh can be really painful
in this you sometimes you'll find that
uh so I know that there's a little seed
Cedar hiding somewhere in here but the
map is very misleading so there's all
this blue over here there could be like
10 bad guys in there right so you might
find that you think I think that I'm all
right here we go and there's there's
another one so now he's he's in a little
bit of danger um but he's got 18 health
I feel pretty good God so crappy he's
got all that life he oh you see this guy
again over here on the left in the upper
left yeah here he is all right
so spread out all right so I can get
this Hunter to kill him I think
go oh for butt sakes that guy has missed
surrounded that guy's missed most of his
attack that that makes me pretty sad
this Hunter down here though mhm I
forget her name what is her name Sherry
old Sherry Sherry Marshall probably have
her move up and and get an attack on
that seed and this one will hit this one
will hit 7% yeah it's fine yes Sherry I
actually didn't know if it would hit or
not my girl I was I was just this is
power of positive I that because you
made this game you knew I just know 57%
of the time it works every
time dang it you asthmatic
fools this guy can't do anything why
don't you hide behind this rock yeah
that's that seems really good I'm really
worried about you all right you're all
done all right take a hit yeah this guy
can take it and early on the first
couple of enemies are not like like
super punishing yeah and I even think
you might have um made it even less like
I remember when I first did it I was
stressing even on my first one I was
like holy crap this is dangerous stuff
uh yeah so so this is um this is on what
we call normal this was a super
interesting thing that I found so we had
when we were balancing the game in Early
Access we only had one difficulty level
and that is actually the one that's one
Beyond this wow was sort of the one that
we were that we were balancing but yeah
we got a lot of feedback that it was it
was too hard it can be pretty
grueling in the beginning to to to lose
especially when you're learning the game
especially when you're learning yeah um
so we we definitely toned it down for
sort of like the Baseline kind of want
to see this charge attack I wish I could
use it looks like it oh yeah you can can
right and it should knock him back and
uh and stun him let's give a
shot I think the stun is incredibly
helpful I love using the stun in this
game because there are enemies that um
the problem with them is that they just
do so much damn damage so you don't ever
want to get a hit ever not once CU
you're really likely to die um so I like
that can I throw it over this rock yeah
you can um yeah you can this is a little
dangerous danger yeah who lives
dangerously though
[Applause]
[Laughter]
YOLO I shav for
this oh man hats off hats off to our
community thanks for possibly the
greatest Victory yell in the history
like it would be really awesome if that
guy had a beard as well I guess you know
when you you you have a beard you
technically still have to shave but
still it's kind of hilarious a dude with
a huge beard or mustache I shaved for
this yeah we had to go through all of
those by hand to make sure that there
there weren't um you know there was
nothing like super egregious that we had
to had to reject completely you probably
had to go through it with a fine com
there are times when you might think
that got it all and then one Sak out my
God it was so hard too because like I
mean we wanted to be working on the game
part of the game cuz that's you know
what matters a little bit more than like
the you know the the text mots that
people are submitting but um yeah there
were just so many of them our uh
producer Anthony vaugh he got super
drunk one night and went through a
couple hundred yeah so I think I think
that some of them some of the sillier
ones maybe if they made him laugh he
just said
I I deserve this oh wait no go back to
this guy there we go Asma attack even he
must hate bridges come on running back
into the dust cowards come here
seed all right you're all dead with my
really really accurate arrow look at
that yes you got another one yes this
guy's going to end up becoming your best
hunter you know this and then you're
just going to have to deal with him we
all all shave tonight
guys you know the great the great thing
about this though is that when you have
a character that you don't like they're
all going to die anyway right you don't
have to put up you don't have to put up
with them forever there's something very
dark about that um that the thing is
about life in
general is that you're all going to die
so you might as well do what you love
whether that be drinking a lot or
um yelling weird stuff after you kill
people or make babies but I mean you're
all dead you know nobody gets out of
life alive isn't that so sad um but at
least you know you get to make a few
babies along the way hopefully hopefully
you do if you're lucky if you're lucky
not everybody yeah so you're retired
right cuz you made a baby that's you
know what maybe I I do think that um you
know I was obviously thinking about a
lot of this stuff like I got married uh
last last year and then had a baby this
year yeah I've been with my fance for a
long time though we've been together for
like eight years so it was not like one
of these like we met on the street and
decided to get married and then have a
baby immediately afterwards some people
not that there's anything wrong with
that some people do that and that's okay
too I just didn't want anyone watching
this to judge
me if anyone judges you for your baby
they can suck an egg oh my God I wish I
had sent a picture of my baby in so that
you could like I could like plug my baby
yeah let it know
you saw the pictures of my baby though
right so excited there's a lot of value
in Eugenics because your baby is
perfect it's it's objectively cute you
know like a lot of times we're talking
about this before too is you know people
don't want to say rude things about your
baby or like about the name or all all
sorts of things cuz oh that was good you
could actually yeah right from there you
can actually shoot um and I wonder if
it's like that with cuteness too if like
people see a baby and it's ugly but
nobody can say that nobody can ever say
that your baby is ugly looks like an
alien like you have to
say wait are you saying my baby looks
like an alien I think all babies when
born yeah look like aliens I don't think
you can escape that he did look like an
alien he did look like an alien the way
it is but now he's like oh he's the
cutest little munchkin love him well
they start to have personality like At
first we were talking about this earlier
is like there were just sacks of meat
and you know like my sister had this
baby and I was just like yeah it's cute
but it's not doing anything and like I
don't know what I expected I mean I'm
the youngest so I didn't understand what
babies were supposed to do I don't know
anything about them they do nothing they
eat CRA they yeah that's right
sleep that's pretty much it your goal is
to keep them alive but then all of a
sudden all of a sudden uh they start
doing really cool stuff and they start
telling you whether or not they like
things and they become very interesting
Little People one HP oh an interesting
thing about the um like because the
melee attacks can't miss yeah whenever
something has one HP if you just go give
it a melee attack it's guaranteed to die
you're guaranteed to die you're
guaranteed to die how does that feel how
does that feel smoo guaranteed um oh oh
and yeah see that that the explosion
when the laps dies it just pushes things
back and if it if stuff gets knocked
into um like a wall or an obstacle or
another character stunned um but right
there there there with that one it
actually pushed that that enemy it it
knocks back Heroes and enemies and it
pushed them right out of the uh fog so
you can see so I'm actually a little
concerned um I'm going to bring this guy
into Harm's Way because this guy only
has 6 hp so I don't want him getting
hurt and this guy's only got eight so
I'm I'm on purpose sacrificing him um
you don't sacrifice Hamachi all right
Hamachi that was tamachi that's so good
I like you know what I'm not memorizing
or remembering any of them because
they're all going to die anyway I'm
deciding not to get close to any of
these people because I definely that was
definitely something we talked about a
lot is that you know people that play
especially like in the Tactical strategy
games like you end up do getting like
really attached to your characters oh
absolutely and that's you can oh you get
you get really sad when they when they
pass that's something like absolutely
that's so excom about this is that
whether or not you want to you will
naturally start feeling for these people
I mean Kelly lamaster is my girl and I
would pretty I'd be pretty sad if she
kicked it she's probably going to kick
it I know I'm sorry but you do like like
we talked about how we want you to get
invested in the actual characters but
they're you know they're like fleeting
but the Bloodlines are the things that
last so so you get adjusted to maybe
last names or yep and so that you see
that um oh Gabriella a party so that was
the there's Mission rewards for all of
the missions that you go on if you win
just got so now you got you have another
uh another Hunter if you want it I will
I will want it um check it out so I'm in
year uh 11 12 here we go more babies
that's right making babies these are
really interesting these are kind of
decisions that I get to make they happen
every you know 15 or so years sometimes
a give or take and uh they can impact
positive or negative depending on what
you choose and you never you never know
I've done ones where I thought I made
the right choice and it came back to
bite me in the butt and I've also gotten
ones and you get like little bonuses if
you choose the right thing so let's do
this there's also everything is like
really random in here like they're
randomly chosen they center around
random Heroes um from your roster and
then uh yeah you just kind of have to
make a decision and usually it's like
some are going to be more risky and some
are more safe but a lot of it is just to
sort of add some more like narrative to
the game because it's like narrative
it's mostly a procedural uh procedural
like procedurally generated game there's
not a ton of narrative in it so these
really like give you some sort of like
little narrative nuggets like throughout
the game and yeah what are you going to
do here I this is I like this breaks it
up for me you know it breaks up the
abely that's another thing it does too
is that rather than just like managing
the nation and then fighting battles
seem like they can't come back to harm
me there's a play it would seem that way
would oh my God you know the answer too
you go to the gardens really there's no
right answer really there's no go and
have a drink I mean oh God I know what
you're going to do I want to have a
drink see I knew it um like to think
that the dirty ostrich the dirty ostrich
that's just a cute play on words and
it's actually really nice place and
everyone there is
lovely um when the ostrich patrons find
out that the ruler will be joining them
a great cheer ensues and the bartender
proclaims drinks are on the house
yeah um drunken ballads gallons of
liquids be consumed and notice that
Camille is enjoying all of it far more
than anyone else so she's gain that
reveler personality so she's drunk now
no so if you use her like like yeah
she'll be she'll be drunk in the next
fight if you choose choose to use her
and also so that's like a permanent
personality trait that she will have
which could also get past down to her
children you made I made one of my
people drunk that's fine far worst
things that can happen like please enjoy
some cake with your people and then they
all get
diabetes oh my God we totally should
have put diabetes in the game we there
is arthritis in the game that only shows
up if your characters are like over 35
it's like one of the Hidden genetics
traits that will pop up when they're
when they're only when they're older
it's so cruel I just there's everything
is so harmful oh graduation yeah so this
is cool so once your characters are 15
so so the kids are sort of bound to the
keep that they're born in uh and then
from 0 to 15 they're being trained by
the parents uh the Regent and the
partner in that keep but then once they
hit 15 they get transferred this was
nemesis little Nemesis this is him oh
the little little Nemesis and you see
he's he's nearsighted too nearsighted
and so so these can't suck a thumb now
you got to put both of them on that
cjack so the P personality traits were
all uh kind of like we roll for those
like once they hit age 15 they get they
get established is that haircut
something that's passed down for parents
cuz it's hideous um feeling we should
put a stop there are a bunch of haircuts
that are like randomly assigned but um
we do have baldness as a hidden genetic
trait so down from the from the mom do
it comes from the maternal maternal
Grand see that's real this is now why
don't you learn something once while
this is good so oh so this guy's a
shadow Jack so if you hit his skill tree
it'll be different from the standard
cjack oh um and he'll be able to like
stealth around I think it happens at
level two um this is exciting all right
so what do I do with him he's just there
yeah he's so he's been transferred to
the capital now so in the next fight
you'll be able to deploy him good old
thumb sucking and then you also got to
start thinking about who's going to
carry on the uh the dice bloodline you
know so if you if you go check in on
there was it the one on the left I think
the keep yeah yeah this was the original
the the dice dice keep house dice see
dice you see all these babies remember
they they both had that Bountiful uh
trait yeah babies they made making tons
of tons of babies yeah so you have can
make twins or triplets things here you
know what we only put we only have twins
I think in a uh one of those random
events one of those text events that
happens we talked about having that but
you know population explosion was
definitely something that we had to man
these are the Baby Boomers yeah this is
the time so if we threw in uh you know
triplets and stuff also I want to say we
have like you've got you've got Kevin
Anna and then Dennis and then you have
Belzer we definitely we definitely threw
all the names like into a big bag and
like for first names and they're just
like all just all just kind of Str
Yeah Anna Anna and Kevin those are the
classic dennises so what are we doing
here we're just looking at them yeah
this is really just like yeah there's
not a lot to do here other than like
brain puny brain bra quick study so you
can see that they share a lot of things
are both now you could you could check
to see if both the mother and father are
brainy because that that brainy trait is
coming out a lot not not hopefully one
of them is yeah okay so that's just
being passed on a lot and under the hood
all the characters have like a big
genetic code we decided to hide it from
you because I just I feel like a lot it
would be overwhelming to see all totally
overwhelming right but but also you know
when the information is there a lot of
people feel like they have to use it and
then they get um I don't know they go
crazy they get panic drive themselves
insane hey your Armor's done my Armor's
done so now you've got like better armor
for all of your Hunters cool I kind of
want to keep with the trend but do you
think is there anything else I should do
this I would go check out the items all
right cuz all the characters have an
item slot and you don't have any of the
research right now these are top hints
for anyone who's interested it's ni to
he knows how to do you know very fast
super yeah like I would just research
that Health file right away and just so
you have that it's like a nice um kind
of a safety net on the battlefield you
only a matter of time before you wish
you had a way to increase the health of
your people because they're going to get
hurt you know you can try to you can in
many ways oh dang it in many ways you
can oh they're going after my they're oh
man all right I'm going to do it okay um
you know in many ways you can avoid
death but people will get hurt so having
those health files or any way to
replenish health is just very very
helpful oh they're getting old yeah this
is one of my favorite parts of the game
like when you're playing the first time
beard yeah see so so who is that that's
Hamachi and he's 59 now Hamachi yeah I
love that where um you know people if
they're playing the game like another
tactical strategy game like if you're
playing it like Final Fantasy Tactics or
XCOM and you're just sort of using the
same characters over and over once you
get to like the third or fourth battle
you kind of get hit with that moment
where you come in here and you see them
on the room of the chalice and you're
like and you're like oh my God they all
have gray hair like this guy's bald
that's amazing so he's got that genetic
bald Tre and you might want to put
Nemesis in right so he's
16 I'll have three C Jacks but I'll do
it yeah I would do
it
nearsighted come on Nemesis make your
Daddy proud
all right we are going to get into this
battle real quick we're going to try to
kill at least one person and then
that'll be that
deploy yeah so that I mean that's kind
of like the full loop of the game and
you're seeing like like at this point
you're already seeing the hybrid classes
like make an appearance and you're doing
that and yeah the so the goal of the
game is to survive 300 years and at that
point uh the Chalice is it's kind of
like charging up and then it's going to
be able to eradicate the Cadence maybe
well ideally is that not what we want
where is that's what you want yeah
Hamachi all right let's get a kill with
Hamachi look at this I'm
surrounded this is a very aggressive
one all right come on Hamachi oh you you
can use okay you want to thr no no never
mind that's great oh he has sneaky
ability the other one the other guy will
have it over there the um
Nemesis the young
guy yeah so if you H Nemesis dice two
oh yeah but he's one of the enemies can
see him so we don't let you turn
invisible well you should be able
to he should always be able to be
invisible at all times look at how
nearsighted he is you see this can't see
anything worthless
Nemesis do something with your
life
yeah right killing them this is like
basically what you're seeing here is
this is like the meat of the game right
now you get a a lot of battles in you
get make a lot of babies get a lot of
fun with it look at all these secret
stuff here lots of implied sex in the
game heck yeah so there is no actual
showing of any of these things it's just
the concept there's no conception in
this game although we know it's
happening yeah you know it's happening
there's proof right the baby is the
proof totally that's the proof that's
how you know um but this is out right
now it's officially out it's no longer
in uh Early Access it's it's like 1.0 on
on Steam so PC Mac Linux and then uh the
Xbox one port also hit and we're part of
the um uh games with
goldes you can actually pick it up and
download it for
uh so if you're paying Microsoft then
you can just download the game for free
that sounds pretty nice and if you do
want it on Steam I think it's $20
normally but I believe you guys are
having a 20% off sale right now I think
that's still going on I think it is
because I checked it before not we'll
we'll make it so we'll make it 20% off
some serious promises no I'm not if it's
not happening I can see I can see like
our business guy watching this and just
like having me make promises of just
like oh yeah like it's totally it's
totally 20% off if it's not 20% off
it'll be it is now actually it's 25% off
everybody there you go um no it's not I
think it's 20% off for this week is what
the thing see that's the thing I've been
on fraternity leave I don't know
anything he he hasn't worked in yeah
it's in like six weeks I haven't been in
the oh that beautiful paternity leave oh
it's really nice is it although I don't
know getting up several times in the
middle of the night to feed your baby
all you had to do was have a baby sleep
deprivation is a real thing sleep
deprivation is a real thing it's rough
it seems like you're fairly functional
which is good it's he's sleeping better
I feel like I'm I'm getting my bearings
now though doing the singing and the
rocking and I do yeah I I can't really
sing but I I sort of sing to him oh
those a good genetic lines and the lines
are gone going here they go they're
passing down those cute lines of genetic
code uh and then erasing the bad ones
from history through murder thank you
for showing us this game Brad it's
always awesome to have you thanks for
having me thanks for having me thanks
for joining us uh that was nassa CH
check it out see you guys
[Music]
later